MALE SPEAKER: Thank you
guys for joining us here
on day two at I/O here in
the YouTube Distribute Space.
And we're so excited
for our final session
here with Adora, who's
the co-founder of Homejoy.
And then before we get
into what Homejoy is about,
your story and talking
about your journey,
we want to talk about what
exactly to expect in this talk.
And basically we're
going to talk about
how do you get your
product out there
once you've designed
and developed it?
How do you get your
first initial customers,
and how you expand
on that distribution?
And really, I couldn't
think of a better example
than, Adora, what you've
done with Homejoy.
So why don't you tell us
a little bit about Homejoy
and what it is
about as a product.
ADORA CHEUNG: Sure.
So Homejoy is a platform
that connects people
with home service providers.
And we started with
professional house cleaners.
So in 60 seconds you
just go to Homejoy.com,
you tell us a little bit
about your place, date
and time for us
to show up, and we
send someone who's
background-checked.
We've interviewed
them in person,
tested that they know
how to clean in person,
as well as they're
insured and bonded.
And they'll show up
at the date and time
you wanted them to show up.
It's meant to be quick
and convenient and very
simple to use.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
And it seems like your
target demographic
are people who can't seem
to keep the rooms clean,
like myself and my housemates.
And it seems that you've
had incredible success
expanding from San Francisco.
And where else have you gone?
You guys moved
internationally recently,
so why don't you tell us
a little bit about that.
ADORA CHEUNG: Yeah.
So we're in over 30 markets now.
If you think of the top X
number of cities in the US,
we're most likely there.
So our top markets are San
Francisco, New York City,
Los Angeles, Miami,
and so on, so forth.
And internationally,
we are in London,
and we just recently
launched Berlin as well.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
That's awesome.
So take me through.
How long has Homejoy
been around now?
ADORA CHEUNG: So Homejoy
has been around for just
under two years.
We started in July of
2012, and basically that's
the month where my brother,
my co-founder, Aaron,
he approached me with
a problem he had,
which was I'm trying to
find a house cleaner,
and I can't find one.
My place is a mess.
So let's try to
fix this problem.
MALE SPEAKER: That's awesome.
So take us through
after you had the idea,
you identified the
pain point, what
was day one like,
when you launched?
ADORA CHEUNG: So day
one was essentially
doing research and doing a lot
of what improvements can we
make to the industry?
And at that time,
we knew that it
was a very old-school industry.
There was not much
technology that
was being used to make-- A
lot of things that were back
then inefficient
are now efficient,
because Homejoy exists.
And so in the marketplace
or on a platform,
you have supply and demand.
You need the customers, who
actually need the cleanings,
and you need the
professional cleaners,
to do the actual cleanings.
And so for us, that
chicken and egg problem
is typically very
hard to solve, but we
figured we could just do
the housecleaning ourselves.
So one day one, we just said
we are the house cleaners.
MALE SPEAKER: You
and your brother.
ADORA CHEUNG: Me and my
brother were house cleaners.
MALE SPEAKER: You were really
going around house to house.
ADORA CHEUNG: Yes.
And we would just need
to find customers.
And so we went around find--
MALE SPEAKER: Why didn't
you call me on day one?
ADORA CHEUNG: I wish
I knew you existed.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, my god.
I would have been your best--
ADORA CHEUNG: I should have
just showed up to Google and--
MALE SPEAKER: That's right.
I would have hired you on the
spot, Adora, I'm telling you.
ADORA CHEUNG:
Coincidentally, we actually
were starting in Mountain View,
so you're actually close by.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
I take even more offense
to that, the fact
that you didn't
contact right away.
ADORA CHEUNG: Good thing
you're a customer now.
MALE SPEAKER: That's right.
That's right.
ADORA CHEUNG: So yeah.
The first day was all about
let's quickly put up--
Within a weekend, we put up
a website, and on the website
so you could book a cleaning.
It was very simple.
And then we went out and tried
to find actual customers come
to our website and
actually book a cleaning.
And it was very difficult.
It took us some time.
We did a lot of
just running around.
At the time it was
summer, July, and there
are a lot of fairs
in Mountain View.
And so we would literally
run around with flyers,
following people and trying
to get them to book cleanings.
And that wasn't initially
very successful.
But there was one day
it was very, very hot.
There was a fair out
on Castro Street,
which was close by my
brother's apartments, which
was our office, too, as well.
And we took water bottles.
We iced a bunch
of water bottles,
took them out, and gave them to
people, because they were hot
and they needed water.
And then we convinced
them, essentially
almost guilt-tripped them
into booking a cleaning.
And that's how we got our
first customers was handing out
water bottles.
So we booked those cleanings,
then we went to go clean it
ourselves.
And what we learned almost
immediately was cleaning
is very hard, and we
weren't good cleaners.
And so at that
point we essentially
decided to learn
how to go clean.
And we first bought books
online to learn how to clean.
MALE SPEAKER: Really.
Like what?
Like "Housecleaning for
Dummies," or what kind of book
did you read?
ADORA CHEUNG: It's
like "Housecleaning
by Martha Stewart."
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, wow!
ADORA CHEUNG: And those
weren't very helpful.
And so we decided actually
the best thing is probably
to just join a cleaning
company, because they
are actual professional
cleaners, and learn that way.
So that's what we did.
So I joined a cleaning
company in San Francisco
and learned how to clean.
But on top of that, what I
got the most out of it was
I learned how a cleaning
company actually works today,
or before Homejoy existed.
There are a number
of things, but just
to give you a couple
examples, for whatever reason,
you couldn't book
a cleaning online.
That seems very basic today.
So we solved that problem.
10 years ago booking
a cleaning online
might not have
worked, because there
was a lot of trust issues
and things like that.
But today, with the
existence of people trusting
to buy products that'll
show up at your door,
they'll buy services.
And a person will actually show
up at the door and do the work.
So on the demand side
was we could do things
better that way.
But maybe more interesting
was on the supply side
of stuff, which is the
operations of the cleaning
company.
In a cleaning company
that has 14 cleaners--
I was the 14th cleaner
at this company.
And every single
day I would show up,
they'd give me a stack of papers
with my customers for the day,
and I would go drive out.
Then those stack of
papers were basically
where the customer was,
specific notes for the job,
and so on and so forth.
It would be four or
five clients a day.
I would drive out
to all the houses,
and then I would drive
back at the end of the day
and give back a stack of papers.
And every single
day was like this.
But if you think of
this day and age--
MALE SPEAKER: It's exhausting.
ADORA CHEUNG: It's exhausting.
By the way, it took me
an hour to get to work.
And then another half an hour
to go drive to the first place.
And then all that transportation
time adds up to a couple hours
where I'm not even doing any
work or going from job to job.
But this is an age--
You have a mobile phone,
you can just-- Why can't we be
in a world where as a cleaner
I wake up, I pull out my
phone, I see all the job notes,
I see the first job I need to
go to, and I go straight there
and then just come back
home and then wake up again
and do it all over again.
I could have had an additional
job or two for the day,
essentially.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Of course.
ADORA CHEUNG: And
then internally, there
were things like the
scheduler system.
What I would see was this
painful cadence of every day,
they would take 14 of us,
look at all the clients,
and painfully schedule
in the best way
for everybody to work
those jobs for the day.
And as an engineer, the
first thing you would think
is I could do this in under
a second every single day,
without anybody,
sitting at a computer
by just creating
software for it.
So these were kind of the things
that it seems obvious today,
but the industry was that old.
MALE SPEAKER: Adora,
I love what you just
said about trying to figure out
pain points that competitors
may have that you can
optimize by essentially going
to work for the opposition.
Would you recommend
that people do
that to identify the pain
points of other competitors
within their industry
if they're not
going into cleaning, per se?
ADORA CHEUNG: Yes.
Yes and no.
I think in a marketplace or
any business thing you go into,
you always need to understand
who your customers are.
And for us at Homejoy,
we have two customers.
We have the actual client who's
getting the actual cleaning.
And to get that experience is
very easy, because you just
go to the platform, and you sign
up, and you get the cleaning.
Our other customers are actually
the cleaning professional
themselves.
And they're here to get
the work opportunities
and to do the work, and that's
why the platform can exist.
And because we're building
so many tools for them,
it's very important
for us to understand
the context of which
they are working.
And so it was very important,
one, for me to actually do it
myself as a founder,
but also it's
very important
for all employees,
from the engineers to
customer service reps
who work at Homejoy, to
have that context as well.
And so one of the
things that you
must do within the first
month you're at Homejoy
is actually go do a
cleaning yourself.
And you go with other employees.
And it helps, as an example,
for the customer service,
then you talk to clients a lot.
And so by doing the
cleaning themselves,
they have context to why we
book a certain number of hours
or why, maybe, a
cleaning professional
did a certain thing or
used a certain solution.
Down to even the engineers.
They're the ones
actually building
the tools for the
cleaning professionals.
And so knowing how
the cleaning works
and how what a cleaner does
helps them design things better
and helps them make
better decisions
at the end of the day.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you think
entrepreneurs nowadays
aren't the end users
of their own products,
that they're just trying
to put things out there
that they wouldn't
use themselves?
It sounds like you're tying
the loop with your team
and everything you're doing.
Do you feel like that's
the case for others?
ADORA CHEUNG: I think those
kind of products tend to fail.
And in fact, before Homejoy, we
had spent three years working
on those type of products, the
products that we wouldn't use,
but we thought
other people would.
MALE SPEAKER: What were
some of those ideas?
ADORA CHEUNG: We
became entrepreneurs
because our mission has always
been to make people happier.
And so Homejoy's mission
is to make homes happier.
And so some other ideas
kind of follow that ethos.
And so the first idea was
a company called Pathjoy.
And it was connecting people
with therapists and life
coaches because
our first thought
was who makes people happy?
Oh, it must be these people.
And so I don't doubt that
they do make people happier,
but we're not the
type of people who
use life coaches and therapists.
And so we just didn't
understand the ins and outs
and the intricacies to build up
a good enough product for that.
And so I think for three
years we essentially
went down this route
of not doing that,
and Homejoy was the very
first idea, actually,
where it was a
problem one of us had
and where we want
to go solve it.
MALE SPEAKER: I see.
So Adora, you've
done an amazing job
of being in over 30 markets.
And it's not exactly
the type of startup
where you just expand online
and hope to get users.
You are literally on the
ground hiring and bringing
in customers.
How do you do that?
What specific things
have you thought about
to distribute it to
different cities?
ADORA CHEUNG: Our
plan had always
been to go into these 30
cities as quickly as possible.
And it ended up being
it took us six months.
And so in order to do this,
you can't change up your plan
from city to city.
It has to be very consistent.
So we basically had
a playbook for demand
and a playbook for the supply.
How to acquire customers
and how to acquire
cleaning professionals.
So on the demand side, what
we did was for every city
we went to, we just
threw a bunch of-- We
raised a little bit of
money by this point,
so we're able to do paid
marketing, essentially.
And so we just did a bunch
of paid marketing stuff,
including AdWords
and things like that,
but what turned out to be
the kicker for almost all
the markets was Groupon.
Typically for local
services, Groupon
is not the best way
to acquire customers,
because there are typically
deal-seekers and things
like that.
But for us, we knew
that if we could acquire
an X number of
customers in a market
and we did a very
good job, we could
rely on them to talk about us.
And then that would
help spread it virally.
And so that's what we did.
So for every market, we
acquired through Groupon.
If it was not Groupon,
it was something
that was like Groupon.
And there were some
cities, like New York City,
where it happened very quickly.
In New York City, after
the first 10 days,
we maybe acquired 100 customers,
and those 100 customers
became 300, and so
on and so forth.
And then maybe some other
cities where it wasn't as dense
and it was slower to pick up.
A couple of cities in
Texas, for example.
In the suburbs it's
a little bit harder.
It took a couple
months before it was.
You're acquiring users, and so
there's just this linear growth
path, and then all of a sudden
there's this hockey-stick kink.
And that's the inflection point
that we're always looking for.
So that's what we did on
the demand side of stuff.
And then on the supply
side, it was actually
even more straightforward.
We basically opened
up a Google Doc
and started writing
down the things
we did to start San Francisco.
And then we handed it over to--
MALE SPEAKER: What
was on that list?
ADORA CHEUNG: On that
list was essentially
there's a pipeline
of how we bring
on cleaning professionals.
So you post a Craigslist ad,
and then you phone screen,
then from the phone screen
they get interviewed in person,
and then from there we
do a background check.
And from there you
do a test clean.
get the first job.
That first job is spot-checked.
And then--
MALE SPEAKER: So you laid
out the whole process.
ADORA CHEUNG: Yeah.
There was a process.
If you think about it
as a car assembly line,
you want to try to optimize
each one of those steps.
MALE SPEAKER: And it all
started with Craigslist.
ADORA CHEUNG: And it all
MALE SPEAKER: That's so funny.
I think you're the
third entrepreneur
during this interview
series who's
mentioned that Craigslist
has been their start in terms
of getting at least a
user base or a clientele,
in your case, the people
who acquire the services.
ADORA CHEUNG: Yeah.
When you're trying
to acquire anything,
you want to look
for avenues that
have huge distribution already.
And so Groupon, for example,
has huge email distribution.
And Craigslist, of course,
has lots of eyeballs.
In our case is job seekers,
which was very good.
So we wrote down all the steps
of how we did San Francisco,
then we essentially gave it to
another person we call a city
launcher.
And the city launcher's
main responsibility
is to go in city, find the city
manager, hire the city manager,
hire the first dozen
cleaning professionals
in the area, with that
city manager teach them all
the systems that
we have in place.
And then once
everything's rolling,
they just exit the city
and go to the next city
and do it over and over again.
And the great thing was while
the framework was very much
consistent from city
to city, the launchers
would be able to
figure out things
do even more efficiently,
or even better.
And then they would
update that playbook.
And now the playbook
is really solid.
So when we launched London
and Berlin recently,
it was pretty
straightforward and resulted
in us being able to actually
grow even faster than we were
able to grow the North
American markets.
MALE SPEAKER: That's great.
So you do get same
person who's going to,
let's say, Chicago
and New York to launch
Homejoy is going to
Berlin and London?
Is this launcher
position somebody
you send out there
and bring back?
ADORA CHEUNG: Yes.
Yeah.
The cadence was basically
every four weeks
they'd be in a new city.
Every four to six weeks
As we've talked about before, it
sounds like a pretty sweet gig.
Because you just traveling
to all these great cities
and meeting new people.
MALE SPEAKER: That
sounds awesome.
So what did it take
for you to say hey,
we need a launcher
as opposed to-- I
feel like so many developers
and entrepreneurs passively
try to put their
product out there
and say we're going
to hope it catches on
in these different cities.
We're going to hope that
cleaners come on our site
and provide the services
in different cities?
Why did you decide to take
a more active approach,
and how do you decide on
that launcher strategy?
ADORA CHEUNG: More and
more active approach in--
MALE SPEAKER: It sounds like
you got an entire pipeline.
You went after the
Craigslist, you
determined you
were going to have
interviews with
all these cleaners.
And it sounds like
you replicated
that process in every
city you went through.
How did you determine that you
had to have a process instead
of just trying for
organic growth?
ADORA CHEUNG: I was thinking in
six or seven months from now,
I want to be in
all these markets.
How am I going to do this
fast and in a way that's
going to be organized?
It turns out it's not
completely organized.
But in my head I was
thinking through the steps.
I think it's a very logical
next step to say OK,
if you want is really
fast, then you just
have to repeat something
over and over again.
That's how you're
going to do it.
It's the idea of just
focusing on one thing
and just doing it very well.
And so that's what we did.
And that's how we decided
just not to change it up.
MALE SPEAKER: And
somebody who comes on
to be a launcher,
they also start
the process of
Homejoy the same way?
They clean the house
before they come on?
ADORA CHEUNG: Launchers have
to clean the most houses ever.
It's not that when
they start, they
have to learn how to clean.
MALE SPEAKER: So maybe
it's not the sweetest gig.
Maybe the traveling--
ADORA CHEUNG: Yes.
It's a lot of great traveling,
but you are cleaning a lot.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
the idea of having
full understanding of
your product and trying
is something you
guys really hit home.
It sounds like whenever somebody
signed up in the early days,
they'd sit next to
the customer service
reps to hear what's going on.
Can you talk about that?
How did you decide that
was the way you should go?
ADORA CHEUNG: I think it's
mostly learning by doing.
What we found is the
people that spent the most
time with the
cleaning professionals
or spent the most time just
really focusing and learning
on a specific thing is the
ones that were more successful,
the ones that were
able to do more.
And yeah, so when an
employee starts at Homejoy,
not only do they
clean, but they spend
a few hours with the
customer service reps,
they actually start taking phone
calls or answering tickets.
If they're not an engineer, they
sit with the engineering team.
They don't watch
them code-- that's
kind of boring-- but they
go through kind of how
the engineers deploy
things and what
are they working on
terms of designing
things and stuff like that.
Yeah, I think everyone
understands in the company
what everyone else
does, and that way you
trust that they're always
working on the best thing
possible, and therefore you
can just focus on your thing
and not have to worry that
something else might not
be going right.
MALE SPEAKER: So now
you built out a team,
you're in over 30
markets, you're
in the US and international.
Why you take us through?
It sounds like on paper just
a very glamorous journey,
but why don't you take us
through some of the battle
scars.
What are some mistakes you made?
What are some things
you want to avoid
so perhaps people
in the audience
could avoid those pitfalls
and work through like you did?
ADORA CHEUNG: I think as you
grow, growing seems glamorous,
but it's actually
very much hard work,
and so you have to commit
to doing the cleanings.
For example, when cleaning
professionals didn't show up
for jobs, employees actually
went and go do them.
And so it's like a commitment
to that kind of hard work
that has to happen.
And I think at a
large company, if you
don't have those type of
people, then it's very hard.
And so you sort of need
to hire for this kind of,
what's the right word?
You have to create sort of
like a stereotype, almost--
who is the right
Homejoy employee?
And then hire for that.
Other things are-- For us,
growing very quickly meant
that we have to
keep the quality up.
Or else, in local services,
like I said before,
at the end of the day, you
can throw lots of money
at acquiring customers,
but that's not
going to really work
in the long run.
If you're not doing a good
job on all the cleanings,
you have a leaky bucket.
No one's going to come back.
And then all the paid
marketing's all for naught.
And so as you grow
really fast, you also
have to think about how am I
going to scale quality as well?
Or how am I going to keep
the quality at a certain bar?
And not grow faster than that.
And I think some of the
early mistakes that we made,
or I made, was going
a little bit too fast
and getting ahead
of the quality.
And then having to come
backward a little bit
and fixing those things
and fine-tuning things
and then going forth.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
So with that, I want
to give you a chance
to talk about any
last piece of advice,
you have somebody who
may be in your shoes
two years ago just trying to
get their product out there.
And then we're going to
open it up to you guys
to ask questions to Adora.
ADORA CHEUNG: I think actually
my biggest piece of advice
is, one, if you have a product,
I frequently see people just
hold back and not launch it.
And I know that there's like
so many blog posters that
just says launch it,
launch it, launch it.
But when it's your baby,
it's hard to launch something
when you don't
think it's perfect.
But you should just do it.
And that's what we did.
We launched something that
was clearly not perfect.
You just learn so much
more from customer feedback
than you ever will with
thinking the problem
through by yourself.
And then second is don't
be afraid to expand.
I think there's a lot
of focus these days--
Yes, you should get
the product right,
and you should be able
delivering great experiences,
but it shouldn't have
to be super-perfect
before you start expanding.
If your goal, if
your dream is to be
a huge billion or
multi-billion-dollar company,
you can't just be in San
Francisco, for example.
You have to be everywhere.
And the customer that
lives in San Francisco
is much different
from the customer that
lives in Dallas, Texas, Chicago,
Illinois, these other places.
And so you have to get to those
people as fast as possible.
And so it's always
think a few steps ahead.
But again, not to go too
fast where you fall over.
MALE SPEAKER: Of course.
So we're going to open up
the audience for questions.
Just project.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
So the question is how do
we decide on the markets?
So in the US it was
pretty straightforward.
People would come to our
site and hear about us.
And then they would
type in their address,
and then we'd say oops, sorry,
we're not in the area yet.
Please check back again.
And so we are able to
see demand that way,
from essentially
collecting ZIP codes.
In terms of international,
London, Berlin, London
is the biggest city in Europe.
There's 12 million people
there, and it's very dense.
And we felt like it
would be almost exactly
like New York City,
which is the case.
Which we found to be the case.
In terms of Berlin,
it's also a big city.
Has 3.4 million people there.
A lot of people get
the technology thing,
and so there wasn't that
barrier or that obstacle
to jump as well.
And we opened up
an office there,
and there's a good
entrepreneurial community
there as well, and so it's
good for hiring talent.
And so all these
factors combined,
we decide to land in Berlin.
AUDIENCE: So when
you're [INAUDIBLE]
I'm assuming
[INAUDIBLE] the fact
that they don't have
to go [INAUDIBLE]?
ADORA CHEUNG: So the
question is what's
the advantage for a
cleaning professional
to work on Homejoy
versus another company?
I think there's two big ones.
One is flexible work.
In this day and age,
the rising trend
is people love to just
work whenever they want.
Actually I think
most people would
love to just work
whenever they want.
But there's an increasing
trend of people
working as independent
contractors.
And so that's the
type of workers
we attract is people who,
for whatever reason--
We have a lot of, for
example, moms on our platform
that work as
professional cleaners.
And they can work from
9 o'clock to 2 o'clock
and then go pick up their
kid for three hours,
feed them dinner, and then maybe
work another gig afterwards.
And so you can't really
find a good job that
allows that slot in
the middle of the day,
and so that's we allow.
And then there are people
who-- Housecleaning
involves traveling around a lot.
The flexibility is also
in the geographical sense.
For example, some people
don't like to cross bridges.
Some people only want to work
in a very specific area, down
to the street.
And we allow for that as well.
And so we have been
able to build up systems
where every contractor,
every professional cleaner
on the platform tells us
exactly when they want to work
and exactly where they want to
work, and schedule around that.
So it's very complicated.
You can imagine the
algorithms involved
in taking everybody's
variations,
but it's certainly possible.
And then the second thing,
which we're getting better at
and which we are very
focused and passionate about,
is building a community amongst
the professional cleaner
community.
Amongst the professional cleaner
base that we have on Homejoy.
And so there are
additional benefits
to working on our platform
besides just getting work.
And so we are very
focused on helping
the professional cleaners
do well and making sure
they have a good life
and things like that.
We don't publicize
those things too much,
but it's certainly something
we do in the background.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome.
We have a question over here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] must have
been a lot of key [INAUDIBLE]
what did you learn in
the process [INAUDIBLE]
be successful [INAUDIBLE]?
ADORA CHEUNG: Good question.
So the question is
what did I learn
in terms of hiring the
key managerial roles as we
grew over time?
There are some roles that
we repeated in each market.
For example, the manager.
And so we developed
profiles of who the best
people were in
terms of launching.
So, for example,
the city launcher,
the best profile we found
was actually consultants.
Like McKinsey consultants.
Because they traveled
around a lot, and they
were very good at just
thinking on their feet
and dealing with random issues.
And very analytical.
We're a very
data-driven company,
and so that helped a lot.
In terms of the city
manager, these are the people
that they're part of
the recruiting process
and they bring on the
professional cleaners,
and they're the
ones interviewing.
And so we felt the best
people for that role
were the people who ran
housekeeping at a huge hotel.
And so in every city, we
would find the top three
hotels in the city
and try to convince
the director of housekeeping
to leave and come join us.
And we're pretty successful
doing that, which was great.
And it helped us.
It meant that we learned
how clean ourselves,
but these were the true experts
in cleaning and determining
who the best cleaners were.
I think the things
I've learned over time
is as we grew from zero cleaners
to 100 cleaning professionals
to 1,000 compressions to
2,000 and so on and so forth,
the operating model
changed as well.
And so different types of people
work in different environments.
So it's sort of from
zero to 100, that's
sort of a typical large cleaning
company, but from 100 to 1,000,
you're trying to think
of not how to manage
each individual person,
you're thinking about how do I
automate some of these
things so that we
can manage 1,000 people at once?
And as we grow even larger to
tens of thousands of people,
we'll have to take that
into account as well.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
So with that, I just want
to thank Adora for her time.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
ADORA CHEUNG: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER:
Enjoyed having you.
ADORA CHEUNG: Yes.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for having me.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, guys.